il
où
et nous on
bonjour à tous ça me fait super plaisir
d'être là en plus je passe en premier
c'est cool je peux avoir des gens qui
vont s'endormir au premier rang je veux
voir toute votre attention et c'est bien
parce qu'aujourd'hui je veux parler d'un
sujet qui est très important à mes yeux
je vais vous parler de ceux qui
réussissent
je vous parlais de ceux qui réussissent
et de comment ils réussissent alors je
vois que j'ai affaire à un public de
plus tôt de jeunes étudiants qui parmi
vous a de l'ambition c'est pas mal c'est
pas mal et c'est important parce que on
a tous de l'ambition on a tous envie de
réussir on a tous des gens qu'on qu'on
idolâtre des gens qui nous donnent à des
mentors on a des gens qui nous font
rêver on a envie de les imiter mais on a
envie de le faire pour les mauvaises
raisons
souvent on a envie de réussir et
d'arbres du succès pour les mauvaises
raisons qui sont en réalité les
conséquences du succès on a envie
d'avoir de la reconnaissance 1 qui on a
envie d'avoir des followers sur facebook
c'est vrai c'est agréable on a envie
d'avoir de l'argent et ça ce sont des
mauvaises raisons mais c'est ce qui
intéresse tout le monde
c'est ça qui intéresse tout le monde
sait ce dont on parle dans les médias
c'est ce qui va frustrer les gens c'est
ce qui va faire rêver les gens
c'est ce qui va faire qu'on va vous
adorez ou qu'on va vous détester mais ce
dont on ne parle pas c'est de ce
cheminement qui mène au succès c'est
vrai ça on n'en parle pas on voit on va
prendre par exemple je sais pas tiens
leonardo dicaprio on va parler de des
soucis qu'il a eu avec un détournement
de fonds pour financer son film le loup
de wall street mais on va pas parler des
centaines d'heures qu'il a passées à
préparer son rôle on ne voit pas les
gens qui ont du succès au travail on ne
sait pas combien de temps ils ont
travaillé on sait pas comment ils ont
fait pour avoir du succès et c'est de ça
dont j'ai envie de parler avec vous
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous donner
quelques conseils qui ont été importants
pour moi et qui j'espère vont vous aider
pour ce long trajet qui mène au succès
et qui est pas un trajet facile donc
voilà j'ai envie de vous préparer un
maximum à ça et la première heure chose
dont j'ai envie de vous parler c'est une
question qu'on me pose très souvent les
gens quand ils me croisent ils me disent
ou est ce que tu vas chercher ta
motivation ou est ce que tu vas chercher
ton énergie c'est vrai que là vous me
regardez j'ai l'air motivé pas vrai
c'est voyager vers motivé pas du tout
pas du tout en fait en oeuvre en vrai je
suis malade donc là la seule chose qui
me motive c'est de retourner dans mon
lit avec une petite verveine ce tilleul
citron avec une touche de miel à
l'intérieur non en vrai je suis pas
motivé et c'est une erreur de penser que
la motivation va vous emmener très très
loin les pouvoirs de la motivation ils
sont pas infinies ils sont pas
illimitées on a tendance à accorder
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup trop
d'importance à la motivation
la motivation c'est très bien pour
démarrer quelque chose c'est génial
c'est ce qui va vous faire ce qui va
vous faire démarrer un projet mais assez
rapidement c'est une source de
combustible qui va s'avérer qui va se
tarir qui va être du coup qui va et qui
va être limité dans le temps il va
falloir renouveler cette motivation bien
sûr mais plus important encore il va
falloir substituer quelque chose à cette
mosquée à cette motivation il va falloir
trouver quelque chose de plus efficace
que la motivation et je vais vous donner
un exemple en ce moment je suis en train
d'écrire un livre
alors évidemment je suis motivé pour
écrire un livre qui seraient pas
motivées pour écrire un livre
c'est vrai quoi on a envie de voir son
livre sur les rayons d'une librairie on
a envie de voir les gens le lire dans le
train dans le métro que les gens
viennent nous en parler donc évidemment
que je suis motivé pour écrire un livre
et la motivation ça m'a permis de me
lancer pour écrire les trois quatre cinq
premières heures mais après quand il
faut retourner au travail c'est beaucoup
plus difficile
la motivation à l'aspc effet au début et
après on se retrouve dans une tâche qui
est rébarbative qui est longue et un peu
chiante si je peux me permettre
est ce qu'il faut que vous ce qu'il faut
que vous fassiez en fait c'est de
réussir à vous attelez vous même est
utilisé en fait les
la façon dont on fonctionne en fait le
l'être humain il aime bien le confort il
aime bien la routine
est ce que vous allez faire c'est que
vous allez mettre en place des routines
mettre en place des habitudes pour vous
assurer de faire le taf et moi ce que je
fais lorsque j'ai écrit mon livre c'est
que je me suis obligé je me suis créé
l'habitude d'écrire tous les jours tous
les jours j'écris tous les jours j'ai
écrit que j'écrive trois lignes que
j'écrive une page tous les jours je vais
écrire et c'est en le faisant chaque
jour à partir d'un à partir d'un certain
temps je vais ancrer cette habitude chez
moi et ça va devenir normal de le faire
j'ai envie d'arriver jusqu'à un certain
point où ne pas le faire va me gêner le
ne pas le faire va me je veux pas me
sentir bien à quoi je fais exactement la
même chose dans mon travail ça fait sept
ans que j'ai monté ma société est depuis
sept ans je travaille absolument tous
les jours alors au début ce n'était pas
facile mais aujourd'hui c'est devenu
très compliqué de prendre un jour de
repos
c'est pas du tout grave puisque c'est
quelque chose qui me rend heureux même
quand je pars en vacances même planche
part en week-end je suis parti en grèce
l'autre jour j'ai pris l'avion jusqu'à
athènes up trois heures j'ai écrit
pendant trois heures je suis revenue
trois heures je crie pendant trois
heures donc j'arrive toujours à trouver
1h 2h ou 3h pour travailler dans la
journée et c'est ce que vous devez faire
lorsque vous avez quelque chose qui vous
tient à coeur
utilisez votre motivation pour démarrer
et ensuite à quai vous implantez vous
discipliner vous pour implanter une
habitude et essayer de de force et de
tenir le plus longtemps possible parce
que cette habitude ne va pas s'implanter
tout de suite il faut quand même passé
un certain temps avant que le le fait de
ne pas faire ce que vous avez à faire
soit à confortable alors il faut pas se
tromper parce que c'est un sujet qui a
beaucoup été discuté et je sais que sur
internet on peut lire des choses comme
oui une habitude savez 21 jours
non une habitude ça mais pas 21 jours il
ya plein de nombreux coups ont été
donnés sur des études qui sont plus ou
moins sérieuses et moi ce que j'ai
remarqué à titre personnel parce que
j'ai du coup j'ai dû j'ai dû me créer
plein d'habitude
que ce soit pour le travail pour le
sport moi je pense qu'il faut plutôt
compter en mois quand jours donc il faut
pas avoir peur au début se dire là je
vais traverser une période qui va être
un petit peu douloureuse
ça va faire un petit peu mal mais une
fois
l'habitude a été implanté c'est très
difficile de la faire partir la deuxième
chose le deuxième conseil que je
voudrais vous donner c'est qu'il ya des
gens qui peuvent vous aider et vous les
voulez soupçonnez pas en fait moi quand
j'étais petit je lisais énormément et ce
que je ce que je faisais c'est qu'une
fois que j'avais trouvé un auteur que
j'adorais j'avalais tous les livres
qu'il avait écrit une fois que j'avais
avalé toute son oeuvre
je vais m'intéresser à sa biographie
ces correspondances en fait j'essaie et
d'aspirer comme une éponge
tout ce que je pouvais trouver au sujet
de cette personne que je vénérais et
c'est un truc qui m'a énormément servi
dans le travail parce que j'ai pris mes
auteurs préférés que ce soit on sait pas
forcément des auteurs qui vont parler à
tout le monde
charles bukowski henry miller marcel
proust mais ça peut être aussi ça peut
être aussi des artistes ça peut être des
artistes français y en a pleins chacun
va aller chercher les gens qu'ils
ambitionnent ces gens là vous devez
prenez les gens vous prenez les gens que
vous aimez pour les gens que vous
admirez et vous devez faire cette
démarche de vous procurer leur
biographie leur autobiographie vous
devez creusez vous devez tout savoir de
leur vie parce que ça va vraiment être
une aide précieuse
vous allez décortiquer la vie de ces
gens là et vous allez avoir une vous
allez avoir une idée de comment ils sont
arrivés au succès parfois ils n'ont pas
eu le succès de leur vivant ils l'ont
eue après when russo sur le tard mais en
faisant ça vous allez découvrir quelle
est la masse de travail nécessaire quel
est le temps nécessaire
quel est l'engagement qui et comment ils
ont fait pour gérer à la fois leur vie
leur vie privée leur vie familiale leur
vie amoureuse et en même temps faire
construire leurs oeuvres faire leur
travail et donc prenez les gens que vous
admirez que ce soit des écrivains
prenait marcel proust prenait des des
artistes renée james bond pour des
michael jackson prenait des
entrepreneurs richard branson steve jobs
peu importe est faite sans vos alliés
fait leur entrée dans votre équipe
et quand vous allez quand vous allez
être en difficulté quand vous allez
avoir un petit peu de mal eh ben vous
aurez l'expérience de ces gens là qui va
vous aider quand vous serez au fond du
trou que votre projet va patiner
vous allez vous référer à l'expérience
de ces types parce que vous allez avoir
dans votre équipe
les plus grands obsédé de travail que la
terre ait jamais porté et ça c'est hyper
hyper important et qu'est ce qu'on va
prend quand on lit quand on lit ces
biographies c'est autobiographie
qu'est-ce qu'on va apprendre on va
apprendre une leçon hyper importante
on va apprendre que le succès sa demande
de la patience le succès ça demande du
temps et ça demande de la patience et ça
c'est un truc qu'on n'aime pas à
s'entendre dire et on aime bien encore
une fois comme je disais au début on
aime bien le succès oui l'argent etc etc
mais ça demande du temps et de la
patience c'est la principale cause
d'abandon chez les gens qui
entreprennent c'est qu'ils avaient
sous-estimé le temps qu'il allait leur
falloir pour avoir des résultats il
avait sous-estimé ce temps là et c'est
un truc qu'on peut avec ce qu'on peut
constater avec un exemple très simple
les gens qui s'inscrivent à la salle de
sport ou qui veulent démarrer un sport
ces gens là en fait ils sous-estiment le
temps qu'il va leur falloir pour
apprécier simplement le fait de faire du
sport et ensuite avoir des résultats
ce sera bien dans ce sens là d'abord on
apprécie le fait de faire du sport et
ensuite on a des résultats
moi je sais que j'ai commencé à faire du
sport je devais avoir 16 ou 17 ans et ça
a vraiment été difficile pendant au
moins un mois
il ya plein de gens qui démarre le sport
ils vont à la salle ils vont ils vont
soulever de la grosse faute
ils vont squatter mais mais mais voilà
une semaine deux semaines
ah non ça fait toujours mal j'ai
toujours plein de courbatures ils sont
pas habitués au fait d'avoir des coûts
voiture ils ressentent pas encore le
les bienfaits que ça peut leur procurer
il faut attendre pour ça donc il faut
être patient et il va falloir être
patient parce que ça va vous demander si
vous voulez atteindre une certaine
qualité
vous allez avoir besoin de patience vous
allez devoir faire beaucoup
il ya une citation que j'aime beaucoup
d'un poète français je crois qui est pas
très connu qui s'appelle léon paul
fargue qui dit j'adore cette citation la
qualité c'est de la quantité assimilé à
la qualité c'est de la quantité
assimilés ça c'est une de mes citations
favorites vous pouvez l'appliquer à
n'importe quoi vous pouvez l'appliquer
au travail vous pouvez l'appliquer à
votre vie amoureuse vous pouvez
l'appliquer au sport ça marche à tous
les coups la qualité c'est de la
quantité assimilés c'est très très très
important de bien comprendre ça et il ya
vraiment il ya vraiment un truc qui m'a
servi dans la vie mais ça a été une
leçon de vie pour moi ça a été plus
important que l'école même quand gêné
quand j'étais plus jeune
mes parents m'ont permis de faire du
sport donc et je fais de la natation et
du piano qui sont deux disciplines qui
sont plutôt ingrate parce que ça
illustre parfaitement cette citation
c'est des disciplines plutôt ingrate il
faut travailler beaucoup avant d'avoir
une bonne technique il faut faire
beaucoup de gamme il faut faire il faut
faire beaucoup d'exercices dans l'eau
pour avoir une bonne technique et on n'a
pas des résultats immédiatement on est
obligé de viser sur une échelle de deux
ans trois ans quatre ans et vraiment ça
c'est un truc qui m'a servi dans toute
ma vie quand j'ai monté ma société après
c'est de dire il faut prendre patience
parce que avoir des résultats ça va
prendre du temps et même si aujourd'hui
je fais plus de piano ou jeune âge plus
autant qu'avant ça m'a quand même ça m'a
quand même
appris cette leçon et puis voilà même si
je retourne à la piscine et bains la
technique que j'ai acquis pendant ses
pendants c'est toutes ces années elle
est restée même si je peux aussi vite
qu'avant
pareil pour le piano si jamais je
voulais réapprendre une pièce
aujourd'hui j'ai encore la technique et
ça revient tout seul il ya un exemple
que j'aime beaucoup quand il s'agit
quand il s'agit de parler de succès de
gens qui ont eu du succès c'est
l'exemple de jk rowling connaissiez jk
rowling harry potter
oui je sais que vous l'avez lu les mecs
ils font jean reno je pollue c'est bon
harry potter c'est un des plus grands
succès si c'est pas le plus grand succès
littéraire du siècle c'est bien possible
vous êtes le livre qui a été le plus
traduit le plus vendu et c'est
intéressant encore une fois de prendre
le succès de cette personne et de le
décortiquer jk rowling elle a eu l'idée
d' harry potter à 35 ans on est dans les
années 90 elle prend le train 35 ans
elle a l'idée d' harry potter voilà elle
dans un train et l'imaginent un petit à
un jeune homme qui va une école voilà
que comme elle dans le train donc elle a
cette idée à 35 ans les années 90
ensuite elle valait travail au portugal
elle va travailler comme enseignante
elle enseigne l'anglais il me semble et
elle veille qu'elle a commencé à écrire
son livre le matin elle va ensuite
passer par une phase très difficile de
sa vie où elle va faire une fausse
couche à va se mettre avec quelqu'un
puis vivons séparés et va passer par une
dépression va vraiment être dans un
quotidien qui assez précaire mais elle
va se déchirer et va écrire un nuitées
jour nuit et jour elle va écrire et
quand son livre est terminée elle va
envoyer les trois premiers chapitres à
une maison d'édition refus une deuxième
maison d'édition refus refus refus refus
d'hier fut jusqu'à ce que son livre soit
publiée et son livre est publié en 1981
17,7 en sept ans ça vous donne une idée
de l'échelle nécessaire pour le succès
et c'est important quand on se lance
quand on entreprend quand on veut
réussir quelque chose d'avoir une vision
forte d'avoir une vision forte de là on
veut aller et ensuite de compter en
années et de revenir dans un travail au
jour le jour et il faut pas se dire
voilà j'ai cette envie de succès l'an
viii
ne mène à rien si on vise le succès pour
le succès cette semaine n'a rien on va
se concentrer sur tout un tas de choses
périphériques et on va pas faire le
travail ingrat qui va mener au succès et
je vais finir cette intervention sur sur
une chose qui est hyper importante
surtout pour vous qui êtes plutôt jeunes
pour la plupart c'est que bat pour
réussir il faut déjà commencer sa part
est content dit comme ça mais il faut
commencer et c'est la chose qui fait
défaut à beaucoup de gens qui qui
voudrait réussir mais qu'ils ne se
lancent pas justement et moi c'est un
truc qui a failli m'en empêcher de
réussir
également il faut être capable de se
lancer il faut être capable de se lancer
d'ailleurs j'ai lu un truc
récemment un sujet là c'est assez
intéressant c'est je parle de cette
intervention à une amie et elle même a
sorti une phrase de hegel on sait pas la
moitié d'un crétin qu'est-ce qu'il dit
hegel il dit la cause de l'indécision
peut également résider dans une certaine
délicatesse de la laquelle c'est qu'en
se déterminant elle s'engage dans la
finitude se donnent des limites et
abandonne ainsi l'infinité mais elle ne
veut pas renoncer à la totalité qu'elle
a envie qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça ça
veut dire que tant qu'on a rien fait bah
tout est possible tant qu'on n'a rien
fait on a encore un champ des possibles
qui est ouverte devant nous on peut
réussir dans tout un tas de manas wesh
pour être champion de tennis à welch
pourrait on peut s'imaginer réussir en
tout un tas de domaines tant qu'on n'a
rien entrepris on est dans cette espèce
de succès fantasmer tout pourrait
m'arriver et il ya beaucoup de gens qui
restent piégées à ce stade là à vouloir
away un jour je voudrais écrire un livre
et à ne jamais se mettre au travail et
c'est vraiment un piège sa part est con
comme piège vesa un piège qui attend la
plupart d'entre vous c'est vraiment la
chose la plus difficile c'est d'ailleurs
un truc un peu c'est un truc qu'on fait
quand on est enfant on vos parents il
vous demandera qu'est ce que tu veux
faire mon petit quand tu seras grand
je vais être pompier à mais je vais le
chercher je veux être et c'est
exactement ça donc on n'a pas envie de
rester piégé là dedans la personne qui
va réussir
c'est là bas c'est pas la personne la
plus intelligente c'est la personne qui
va être capable de passer à l'action
parce que le succès c
c'est passer à l'action c'est que pas se
passer à l'acte au début et ensuite
c'est une succession d'actions et voilà
on est sur un parcours qui va être
parsemée d'échecs et chacun ses échecs
va vous amener un peu plus près du
succès et moi c'est un truc qui a failli
arriver aussi
j'ai failli ne pas nous retrouver ici
quand j'avais 24 ans je faisais un
travail à paris de consultants qui me
plaisait pas du tout je m'ennuie à mon
travail je comptais les secondes jusqu'à
la fin de la journée je me cachais dans
les salles de réunion je disparaissais
comme ça pendant les gens et traille
c'est un travail que je détestais
vraiment je le détestais mais je
continue à le faire est vraiment j'ai
découvert que la pire chose la pire
chose c'est l'ennui le pire sentiment
c'est l'ennui c'est ça qui vont en fou
est la chose la meilleure qui peut vous
arriver cette vous épanouir dans ce que
vous faites et au final c'est le travail
qui va vous amener à ça et ce qui m'est
arrivé c'est que j'arrivais pas quitter
ce job est un matin je me suis fait
fauché par une voiture est aussi
horrible que ça puisse paraître
j'ai eu de la chance parce que je m'en
suis bien tiré mais ça a été pour moi un
déclic ça a été pour moi un déclic
si tôt que j'ai été rétabli j'ai rédigé
ma lettre de démission
je savais absolument pas ce que j'allais
faire derrière mais ça m'a permis de me
lancer et le message que je voudrais
vous faire passer aujourd'hui c'est le
message que j'aurais voulu recevoir
avant cet accident j'aurais voulu
comprendre ça avant d'avoir ce stupide
accident j'aurais voulu qu'on me dise
voilà le succès c'est quelque chose que
tu décides alors n'attendez pas merci à
vous
[Applaudissements]